hey there fellas put the kids to bed
cause today we're gonna tell you about
the opportunity of a lifetime we know
you're used to getting spoon-fed some
lame anomaly by the squares that scp
explained but don't worry we gave them
the night off it's just you and me allow
me to introduce myself i'm the
proprietor of a certain specialty
gentleman's club that caters to her well
let's say discerning clientele you won't
know my name what are you a cop get out
my face anyway believe me when i say the
operations of my totally legitimate
business are deeply tied to the
activities of some of the knocks at the
scp foundation there are plenty of
so-called scary scps or awesome scps or
god forbid
wholesome scps but i don't care about
any of that the real question is what
scps are the hottest and i don't mean
how it doesn't literally physically hot
you dengues like scp-001 the gay
guardian and his crazy solar sword
though i wish my bounce had one of those
would be nice to chop the freeloaders in
half either what do you call it the
atomic level or what have you i'm
talking about scps that are total smoke
shows and no i'm not talking about
scp-3792 an aerosol can full of black
smoke that forms humanoid figures but
hey if you enter that i can see what i
can do i'm talking about the kinds of
scps that they put in adult content
warning in front of like a cp-4960 a
literal sex and fertility goddess lovely
woman by the way we worked together
briefly in the 60s but that's a story
for another day maybe you're more on the
furry side of the equation with scp-1471
and you download mal-o version 1.00 like
it's tinder because you want an
appearance from scp-1471-a
if you have a thing for silver foxes
maybe
scp-106 tells you a few of his war
stories might be a good way to pass the
time and if you ever think for literal
foxes
scp-953 the polymorphic humanoid might
be up your alley sure she might trick
you into killing your friends and eating
your own organs but
ain't she gorgeous and maybe even
thinking about the scarlet king in this
big hunky sulabama makes you blush as
red as blood he loves spilling look i
ain't here to judge we are like a bad
boy and it doesn't get much better than
an interdimensional tyrant who wants to
destroy the whole multiverse if any of
this got you feeling a little hot under
the collar and you've confirmed already
that you're not just experiencing a
fever from a rapidly progressing scp-008
infection then my classy little joint
might be the perfect recreational
establishment for you of course we work
on a kind of honor system here so i'll
tell you about all this on the download
as long as you promise to keep it to
yourself capisce because if you
double-cross me on this one some broken
thumbs and pride off kneecaps will feel
like a free vacation from what i'll do
to you if you want to find us head on
down to east st louis corner of redacted
street and redacted avenue we're pretty
easy to recognize from the outside we
look like a single story brick building
with real pretty colors come over to the
west side of the building on saturday at
2 a.m and party boy we will give you the
time of your life you'll know it's time
for the fun to begin when my boy big
mike exits the building and starts
setting up the signs one will be a
sandwich board with a schedule of the
night's entertainment the other is my
pride and joy
the big neon beauty on the side of the
building reading exotic girls or
equivalent welcome to the multiverse
strip club you make your way in with a
few hundred bucks and trust me you're
never gonna wanna leave though full
disclosure we will boot you out on your
ass if you decide to linger after 3 30
when the show ends if you're still alive
at that point did i just stay alive no
hard then you just hearing things you
should really speak to a professional
about that look i'm not gonna treat you
like a schmuck i could tell you about
how great the experience at my club is
until the cows come home but what reason
do you have to trust me how about
instead i tell you about the special
night a bunch of scp foundation
d-classes spent in my club on their
bosses dime i don't know how much you
know about the barbaric practices of
those squares at the scp foundation but
they ain't big on human rights they
found out prison inmates to be their
personal guinea pigs and they have the
goal to call us unethical being a
d-class is a thankless job they get
sacrificed to monsters on the rag and
put in needlessly dangerous situations
now if 106 escapes one of them gets put
in a femur breaking machine so their
screams of pain lure him back if anyone
deserves a night of sexy fun in my club
it was these three guys here even a
class d becomes a vip and believe me we
hire our fair share of double d-class
personnel here too and we treat them
right if you know what i mean the
d-class is waited outside the club for
big mike to come let them in then paid
the door charge with their foundation
mula those jerks at the scp foundation
made them all bring in notebooks and
pens to document everything they saw
talk about adding insult to injury you
can't enjoy a night out if your head is
stuck in a stupid notebook the whole
time you want your head stuck between a
pair of
wait this is a family show oh
ask your mom about that stay in school
kids needless to say when those
d-classes got inside they were real
impressed with what they saw our
establishment may not look like much on
the outside but on the inside baby we
got it all
fine shag carpeting mirrored walls a
disco ball luxurious and comfortable
seating and a thick fabric curtain
around the stage where the brass pole
waits the guys were excited to get some
more action and we were more than happy
to oblige we started them off nice and
easy with the kunbish sisters the
hottest pair of babes the tuvan republic
has to offer they have this incredible
routine where the pair of them sit naked
on a log and begin an incredible round
of tuv and throat singing the exact same
routine they did in eurovision 1999
while giving each other a tasteful
shiatsu massage clearly the d-class
fellas were enjoying themselves because
they made it rain on that stage and the
kunbish sisters repaid their kindness by
singing a faster throat singing diddy
which they performed in eurovision 2003.
next came one of my favorites helen
keller took the stage a woman as
inspirational as she was hot dressed in
the vegas showgirl outfit arwga am i
right fellas she did a very classy strip
show for the d-boys while performing a
choreographed dance routine to the song
from flash dance when the guys made the
range she put a pause on the dance
routine and decided to recite some
poetry which moved the boys to tears and
also led them to making it rain a little
more on old helen we figured by this
point the boys were a little more
acclimated to our special brand of
sensual entertainment that's when we
decided they were ready for the
entertainment stylings of the fantastic
zippy and trainer if you thought the
combi sisters were dynamic to offend
buddy you ain't seen nothing yet it's a
lady and a live orangutan oh and the
lady has no head and also advanced
necrotizing fasciitis fun fact that's a
flesh-eating disease but don't let that
put you off they don't call her the
fantastic zippy for nothing train up the
orangutan gives the fantastic zippy
verbal commands to hit the pole and do
her routine sure some parts of her might
fall off in the process but that's only
because she puts so much energy into it
when one of the declasses through her
five dollar bill she slipped it into her
exposed trachea and the trainer ordered
her backstage finishing a routine that
the surviving d-glasses would never
forget did i just say surviving no i
didn't you're just imagining things come
on let's move on we decided after giving
them a performer with no head to make
sure the next performance had a little
more bite we released the girls which is
to say four velociraptors in perfectly
tailored japanese maid outfits they took
to the stage with plenty of growling and
snarling the d-classes admittedly
started to look a little fearful but
i've always thought of fear as the
greatest aphrodisiac i can only imagine
that's why two of the 3d classes decided
to throw literally all of their money at
the stage for these four very special
gals the other d-class split the rest of
his money between the trio as the
raptors left bringing their spicy
performance to an end still i think
maybe these raptor gals have a future
and more mainstream entertainment
especially if they cross over with the
scp foundation maybe we'll call it dr
kondrakki's raptor maids i don't know
we'll workshop the title give
suggestions in the comments next we
prove to these d-classes that we can
also stay up with the times and provide
the cutting edge in sleek modern
erogenous technology we did this with
erratic underscore performance.exe
a program that runs on the incredibly
advanced gateway 2000 computer and
monitor running a fence run 98 operating
system it hit those boys with a series
of equations and 3d graphical
representations that would surely drive
any hot-blooded fellas totally wild in
the end they inserted a five-dollar bill
into the computer's floppy disk drive
and we moved them on to the next
performance the council of libidinous
elders were brought in next to switch
things up what you've never heard of
accounts of the bitterness elders and
you haven't lived my friend each one is
a levitating gelatinous mass filled with
membranous fibers with powerful
telepathic erratic abilities they sent
mental transmissions directly into the
brains of those lucky d-classes leading
to feelings of brain pain mild acute
tinnitus and most importantly of all
overwhelming physical stimulation baby
we only had two performances left for
them at this point the first was a
little number we like to call serial
number two two three two four four dash
zero nine p okay we lied the number
wasn't that little this babe was all
legs literally she was just a pair of
mechanical legs attached to an engine
powered by pure ambergris when the
ambergris is poured in she starts the
most elegant river dance you ever did
see and for you crush fans out there we
even put blades full of beetles
underneath the legs so she can smash
them all up oh the d-classes they loved
it until the pungent musk of the crushed
beetles made them feel a little nauseous
ah that's what love smells like and for
our most awaited performance of the
night we brought in a special performer
the foundation dweebs call him
scp-1093 but i call him something else
that i'm not allowed to tell you he's a
handsome dude wearing a sumo style
mauashi with a head so bright you
literally can't see it's a highly
radioactive ball of pure light and the
version of him in my club also came with
a big sexy ornate stone ceremonial knife
he leaped into the crowd and wrestled
one of the d-classes before using the
knife to remove their organs in a
horrifying ritual sacrifice did i say
that
no no no
you're just imagining things don't just
hear about it happening to other people
come on down to the multiverse strip
club we'll give you a night not even any
sticks will make you forget now go check
out trapped in a game
scp-1733 season opener and
scp-1861 the crew of the hms
wintershimer for more anomalous spaces
you certainly wouldn't want to be
trapped in